so today we'll be talking about lifelong
learning its first logistics the project
milestones are doing Wednesday and next
week we have two guest lectures by Jeff
Clun and Sergey xi and I highly
encourage you to attend in person I
think that their talks will be pretty
neat talking about probably talking by I
don't know the particular topic of just
lecture yet but I'll probably be
covering things like evolutionary
methods more advanced topics in lifelong
learning than the things only cup be
covering today as well as other kind of
interesting topics in the context of
control animation evolution those sorts
of things and then Sergei Levin will be
talking about information theoretic
exploration and unsupervised
reinforcement learning and how that can
be pertained to a form of like passive
agnostic reinforcement learning where
you want to pre train before knowing
what task you're gonna be doing okay so
the plan for today is Ruby talking about
lifelong learning and before I go over
the outline I guess I'd like to preface
this preface this lecture by saying that
in many ways lifelong learning it I
think is a very active area of research
and a very open area of research and I
don't think that as with a couple of the
other lectures in this course I think
there may be more questions than answers
and so I'm gonna try to have some some
interaction and some engagement with
regard to some of those questions so
that we can think about them in the
lecture as well so first we'll be
talking about the lifelong learning
problem statement then we'd be talking
about some basic approaches to lifelong
learning and then we'll think about can
we do better than these basics and we'll
see two examples of ways that we can do
better and then revisit the problem
statement of lifelong learning from the
perspective of middle learning okay
so let's first to start by talking about
the problem statement and this is
actually probably one of the biggest
topics of the lecture which is how do
you actually formulate the problem of
lifelong learning and to review the type
the two main problem statements that we
focused on in this course have been
multitask learning and meta learning
which may be in the context of
supervised learning
reinforcement learning and multi-touch
learning the goal is to solve some set
of tasks and then perform those tasks
and in metal learning the goal is to use
experience from a set of tasks to be
able to quickly learn new tasks and so
the motivation behind things like
lifelong learning is that in practice
unlike these problem statements are kind
of the real world may look like
something like this where we don't have
access to a set of tasks right off the
bat and instead we need to be learning
in a more incremental or online fashion
where we are given objectives one of the
time and we say to data in a stream
rather than in a batch and so this this
is kind of a general temporal view of
multitask learning or meta learning is
it's kind of what underpins the kind of
idea behind things like lifelong
learning
so some examples of this that I came up
with there are many other examples of
lifelong learning systems in that we may
want to be able to create so one example
is a student learning concepts in school
learning for example math concepts
ranging from simple addition to long
division to - yeah algebra calculus etc
another example might be say you are you
have some image classification system
and you want to deploy it to help
classify people's images for different
users and if it's deployed in the world
it will be seeing a stream of images and
it will be given different tasks over
time and I mean maybe a stationary
distribution of maybe a non-stationary
distribution because the world is
changing and also the kinds of pictures
that people take change over time
another example is something like a
robot acquiring an increasingly large
set of skills and different environments
so in practice we we may want robots to
do many different things and we may not
know right off the bat everything that
we may want the robot to do so instead
we want to kind of have this sequential
setting also in that kind of in the
context of language you could imagine a
virtual assistant helping different
users with differ
different houses different points in
time or something like a doctor's
assistant aiding in medical decision
making decisions in each of these cases
I guess one of the key ideas behind
lifelong learning is that when you
deploy a machine learning system it
shouldn't be fixed you shouldn't just
kind of keep it's weights the same and
deploy it and run it instead it should
be continuing to learn based off of the
data that it sees and that will allow it
to handle challenges relating to
non-stationarity and challenges relating
to its seeing tasks that it wasn't
trained to do in the past okay so with
that in mind first some terminology so
you can just broadly view this class of
problems as a form of sequential
learning problem where you're given data
you're given tasks in sequence but there
are a lot of different terms that have
been used to describe these kinds of
sequential learning settings ranging
from things like online learning
lifelong learning continual learning
incremental learning streaming machine
learning or streaming models or
streaming data I think all of these fall
under the category of sequential
learning the in general the community
doesn't use consistent terminology for
many of these terms
unfortunately so I think that the all of
you I'll define a couple of these terms
I throughout the lecture but otherwise I
think that when reading the literature I
wouldn't necessarily assume that these
mean different things they may all just
mean the same thing whether and that's a
bit too satisfying I know but and maybe
in the future we can try to actually
assign different names these terms are
or better defined the types of things
that we're talking about and it's also
worth mentioning that this is distinct
from sequence data for example if it's
something like language is a sequential
form of data but that doesn't mean that
you're learning from it in sequence you
but you could still have a batch of
sequential data that you're learning
from and likewise this is also different
from sequential decision making i things
like reinforcement learning are a form
of a sequential decision making problem
where you're the actions that you take
at your current time step effect the
next action but you could also do
sequential decision-making in a batch
setting where you're just given one
environment and one batch of data from
that environment and you want to learn a
policy and so these kind of there's like
kind of like three different forms of
viewing sequential data sequent
decision-making in sequential learning
and in this lecture we'll be focusing on
sequential learn okay any questions okay
so I wanna do a little exercise so I
don't think that there's really as I
kind of alluded to before I don't think
there's necessarily any consensus to
what the lifelong learning problem
statement is and I think that actually
in many different contexts it will vary
based off of the things that you care
about in that application and so what
I'd like to do in the next like I don't
know five to ten minutes is have each of
you pick an example problem setting from
the example problem settings that I
showed on the previous slide and I'll
bring them back up again and then and
maybe also pair up with someone or form
a group of two or three and discuss the
problem statement corresponding to that
problem setting with with your partner
and in particular try to answer the
questions such as how would you set up
an experiment in order to develop and
test your algorithm and this will kind
of help you identify the sort of actual
underlying problem statement underlying
that example what are desirable were
desirable or required properties of the
algorithm as they pertain to different
things like memory privacy data those
sorts of things what things do you want
out of your algorithm in that problem
setting and then also how do you
evaluate a system so if you have an
algorithm that can solve the lifelong
learning problem how would you actually
go about evaluating whether or not it's
doing a good job or doing a bad job okay
so here are the example settings that I
showed on the previous slide if you want
you can also come up with a new example
setting if if you're feeling creative
and I'll give you a few minutes to chat
with chat with someone else in the room
about these problem statements ready go
oh and then afterwards I'm going to ask
you guys to say what you discussed and
what was specific to that problem saying
alright are we ready to regroup or do
you need another minute
raise your hand if you think you need
another minute okay look let's regroup
and you guys you guys didn't think oh
I'll go dizzy you guys lost okay so
let's start with this group right here
so what which example did you pick and
what were your considerations for a B
and C okay so like negative backward
transfer yeah all right
you can keep on talking like that
ability to generate new tasks and how
you how would you evaluate that ability
[Music]
okay cool yeah so the experimental set
would have like increasingly difficult
tasks okay so yeah seeing if it can
generate a broader range of tasks and
you probably want something in addition
to just entropy of that task
distribution may be also something
relating to whether that there solvable
tasks or something okay cool
anything else dad right so you're saying
that maybe you don't need to maybe it's
okay to forget some things okay cool
okay next room
okay so you're saying that basically you
want to maintain a distribution over all
of your previous tasks and evaluate it
on all of the previous tasks all right
cool
I'll put that under evaluation and then
the second point was maybe maybe you
don't care about all the past Hospital
upset of them or a certain distribution
over them yeah okay cool anything that
was different from the first group that
you felt like wasn't important
yeah so like where does the curriculum
of cows come from yeah yeah that's a
good question
I guess I don't really have a box for
that but yeah that's good okay next year
both into the learning process okay cool
I feel like evaluate about combinations
of like tasks environments variations on
the tasks what yeah
yeah so I could continuous
parameterization of tasks okay
they group in the middle
yeah so you want some sort of kind of
memory of the past and also you may have
like periodic signals like seasons for
example and you want to be able to take
that into account in your
decision-making to do perform well I
guess the in addition to transfer the in
generate new tasks there's also just
generally like good performance is
something that we care about yeah
yeah and that's padieu clearly relevant
if you're seeing like out of
distribution data for example yeah yeah
so considering like different sequences
of tasks and you want it to be
potentially robots to those different
types of sequences if you're in a like a
medical decision-making situation
because you don't know if you're gonna
see be seeing easier cases to harder
cases or if you may see some intermixing
of hard cases and easy cases great ok
they group in the back
yeah yeah that's a good point like if
you have if there's one user that you've
been repeatedly seeing a lot and and and
very recently then you may want to like
focus some of your representational
capacity on that user because it's
likely that in the near future you'll
see them again and you want to be able
to make good decisions then great group
in the middle
like a course affine type approach right
so you might have kind of course defined
type of tasks and mail so you care about
like learning efficiency like be able to
learn more quickly as you see new
concepts in the sequence I'm not sure if
course defined falls under evaluation or
properties but I think that this this
kind of gray area is what makes these
sorts of problems
so yeah so yeah like evaluation on like
yeah this is like yeah yeah so kind of
like maybe a generation of new tossed
but from unlabeled data so like oh and
memory like little oh then memory
okay I'm going to put this next to
active learning because like it can
actually get great wouldn't it be good
for the morale to be able to expand its
parameters in its architecture so now
how yeah
so like a dynamic architecture capacity
okay um Chris Shawn did you overcome
yeah they also suspect that something
like generalization versus
specialization is gonna be something
application dependent like in many
situations you may care about like it
being like very consistently performing
very well in this situations where you
really need to perform well versus being
able to do something like do more things
but slightly at a lower degree of
performance like a robot doing things
with like a lower success rate or a or
it like more slowly than if it were a
specialist that was specifically tuned
for doing one particular task right so
when they propose their own tasks they
should propose things that are useful
and ethical yeah okay great I think that
was a great discussion and I think that
I guess one takeaway from this is I
think that in different applications you
care about different things like in some
applications you really want it to kind
of remember everything and be able to
perform well in a wide variety of
situations whereas in other applications
you care a lot more about just the
recent thing and the things that it
needs to do now so for example in a
decision-making situation you don't want
to forget past events you want they want
to be able to recognize new trends when
they're happening whereas in a student
learning concepts in school maybe maybe
they don't need to maybe if they're not
using very basic long division skills
maybe they don't need to remember those
long division skills because they're not
actually useful for their current
position I don't know if I don't
personally don't use long division a lot
so I don't
I think it's okay if I forget that
particular skill for example okay okay
so let's let some I wrote out some
problem variations and and evaluation
considerations on the slide just to kind
of I think that we probably covered most
of the things here but we can go over
some of these things so one variation is
how the tasks come to the agent so we
talked about this a little bit they may
come in a curriculum from easy to hard
or they may be more something like iid
where you see both a range of difficult
house and hard and easy tasks in some
sort of stream there's also a setting
called predictable which is a general
it's it's a less strong notion of iid
it's similar to the seasons for example
if you know it's kind of the end of
summer you know that it fall is likely
to come and so you can see that sort of
trend in your stream of data and then
there's also I don't think it was
covered in any of these settings but
there's also settings where you have
adversarial tasks coming in and that
might be if you have a competitive
environment and you're trying to learn
how to compete against another agent
then the types of tasks that may be
coming in are gonna be a task that are
particularly targeted towards the types
of tasks that you do poorly at and so
that's also a variation of the lifelong
learning problem statement and the type
of algorithm that you develop may be
very like very much influenced by these
different types of categories another
variation of the problems is whether or
not you have very discrete task
boundaries or more continuous task
boundaries this came up we're talking
about having your task be continuously
parametrized versus having more discrete
tasks and then there's also situations
where you know where the task boundaries
are and where you don't know the task
boundaries are so for example if if
you're in grade school you if you're
going from first grade second grade or
you're given one problem versus another
problem there's pretty clear shifts but
if you are diagnosing flu symptoms or
making diagnoses for the flu you may not
know shifts in the data distribution
that you're seeing do you have a
question oh cool some considerations in
terms of like the desirable properties
that we care about model performance as
we discussed data efficiency the ability
to learn new things quickly we didn't
really talk about this but computational
resources and this is actually going to
come up a fair amount and thinking about
the algorithms that we develop and it's
related to this memory but in terms of
computation you don't want the
computation to grow with I grow linearly
in n for example as you see more tasks
and then there's other considerations
such as privacy interpretability
fairness and the amount of computing
memory you use at test time a lot of
some of these things are things that you
care about in standard machine learning
settings and aren't specific to lifelong
learning although one thing that comes
up that we'll touch on in a couple
slides is privacy if you're in the
medical decision-making setting for
example it may not be you may not be
allowed to actually store all of the
data perpetually and so that may
motivate settings where you have to
store things in the memory of the neural
network rather than storing them in in
plain text although in that setting it's
it's unclear if you're storing things in
the weights of a neural network maybe
you're still storing them and maybe
that's also violating privacy patient
privacy so some kind of interesting
philosophical questions there yeah so in
general substantial variety in the
problem statement and unfortunately all
of these generally fall under the
umbrella of lifelong learning or online
learning and so it makes it rather
difficult a bit to tease apart some of
the different advances in this area okay
so now let's look at one very concrete
instantiation of the lifelong learning
problem statement and this typically
falls under what's called online
learning and it's very simple so you
have a time that's passing and you
observe an input
you make a prediction about the label
corresponding to that input and then you
observe the label for that input and
then the loop iterates this is basically
vanilla online learning and in the very
general case you could make no
assumptions about what X is and what Y
is and also in the general case you
could just you you could not place any
restrictions on memory on computation
and just want to be able to solve this
problem in the terminal case so that's
the most general formulation of the
problem you may make some certain
assumptions so one assumption that you
can make is that the data is coming in
iid so the XT is drawn from P of X and
YT is drawn from P of Y given X and note
that P is not a function of T so it's a
stationary distribution this is one
example of online learning and this
assumption can make it easier to think
about algorithms even if the data
density doesn't necessarily follow these
assumptions otherwise if you assume that
you're not in the ID setting then you
assume some sort of time varying
distribution over X and Y given X and
there's other as they eluded to before
there's also a setting called the
predictable setting that I don't have
text for but that's the setting where
you can actually predict something about
the next distribution based off of the
trends you've seen in the past okay so
another assumption or another
consideration or restriction that you
can put on this is what I'm going to
call the streaming setting and in this
study you can't store XT and YT you can
only look at them once and then you're
kind of given the next thing you're not
allowed to have any memory and so this
could be very useful if you're in
settings where you have don't have any
memories or just the amount of data the
quantity of data is so enormous that
it's impractical to think about storing
it due to memory order due to
computational resources if you have
streaming video for example every single
second it may be impractical
that it could also relate to privacy
considerations as I mentioned before and
it could also relate to wanting to study
neural memory mechanisms so there's a
kind of a subfield of lifelong learning
that really cares about how humans
remember things when they're given a
stream of data and so if you care about
kind of this biologically plausible form
of memory that is more biologically
plausible than like a hard drive then
you could consider this setting and it's
worth mentioning that this is certainly
true in some cases that you cannot store
x and y but in many cases it is actually
practical to store the data that you're
seeing we have very large data sets like
image net we have pretty big hard drives
and so from a practical point of view it
can be actually very sensible to store
the data that you're seeing for a range
of problem settings so for example in
reinforcement learning settings we store
our data and replay buffers and we
particularly replay or get that data so
the agent in order to allow it to
continuously learn from that data okay
and then the last variation on this
problem statement that I had written
down is that if you know where the task
boundaries are you may also be observing
some task descriptors et that could
correspond to a one hard vector or some
other more descriptive description of
the task and in that case you would
observe both XT as well as the task
descriptor although you could also put
this into the general case of online
learning where xt contains both the
input and the toss descriptor okay so
this is the problem statement or several
different variations on a general
problem statement now what do you want
from your lifelong learning algorithm
and in particular how do you go about
evaluating lifelong learning algorithms
there are two metrics that I or or two
classes of metrics that I think are
useful for thinking about this and I
actually I don't think it anyone really
gave a concrete metric when we were
discussing this before so let's talk
about that now one of the most
classic metrics and online learning is
what's called regret and you want to
have minimal regret and you want your
regret to grow slowly with the time and
because our what regret refers to is the
cumulative loss of the learner so
essentially the the integral of the loss
for each of the data points that you see
subtracted by the cumulative loss of the
best learner in hindsight so this is
basically a comparison between your
cumulative loss and what you could have
done in the best case and mathematically
what this looks like is the following so
say theta t is the parameters that you
choose at each time step to make
predictions the humilated regret of
accumulative loss of yourself is the
left term where you're just adding up
the loss for the set of parameters that
you used at each time step and the right
term is referring to in hindsight if you
had some model that that minimized the
loss for those time steps basically kind
of the best set of parameters that you
could have done or you could have used
to perform that sequence of tasks okay
yeah yeah so this cannot be evaluated in
practice typically but it's very useful
for analysis and and inputting that
we're thinking about in in simplified
settings usually in convex settings can
we study how the regret grows for these
algorithms
so one thing worth noting is that regret
that grows linearly and T is trivial to
obtain can anyone tell me why that is
the case
um let's see
so if you right so if you output kind of
a random parameter vector it would grow
linearly in T you could actually do
slightly better than that and still have
it be linear are there any other so that
that's a good example are there any
other examples of where you could get a
loaner that is linear and T yeah mm-hmm
so if you keep theta fixed at like a
random initialization at any performance
what do you mean right so you don't get
to choose the loss you only get to
choose theta if you keep theta fixed you
won't necessarily have the same loss for
all of the tasks does that make sense
although if you have a random theta you
would you give you just that you would
probably have the similar loss for all
the times I guess the same thing for
fixed any other thoughts yeah
yeah yeah so if you just train from
scratch on each to the T tasks and
disregard any previous experience then
you would get linear regret because the
loss or assuming that they lost the
tasks are a similar difficulty if you
just train on each of those tasks from
scratch yeah you would get linear regret
and because the the loss the boss value
would be constant and so the loss would
would increase and so in practice what
we typically want is a sub linear growth
in your regret so that you can actually
use your previous experience to do
better on the future tasks okay cool so
that's one metric that's used typically
in the online learning literature and in
practice as I mentioned it's something
that's very difficult to evaluate so
let's think about some sub metrics that
we could actually evaluate in practice
and so I think the most common metric
that people use in lifelong learning is
thinking about positive and negative
transfer so you guess first you can look
at performance on on your set of tasks
but in addition to performance you could
look at how well your tasks are allowing
you to perform other tasks and so
particularly positive forward transfer
refers to a setting where previous tasks
can cause you to do better on future
tasks compared to learning the future
tasks from scratch so if you basically
compare how will you do on future tasks
after learning the previous tasks
compared to learning future tasks from
scratch that can give you a measure of
positive transfer and positive backward
transfer would be if a current task
allows you to do better on previous
tasks and this would be compared to
learning those past House from scratch
before seeing your current tasks and
then if you wanted to find negative
transfer just replace the word better
with the word worse and you'll get
negative transfer if you're doing it's
basically previous house calls you to do
worse on future tasks and the
Tass allow you to do or cause you to do
worse on previous tasks okay so this is
a metric that can allow us to study
whether or not lifelong learning is
allowing us to learn well right so
typically it's not a symmetric metric so
for example if you learn how to what's
an example this if you if you learn how
to grasp objects and then you learn how
to grasp an object and put it into a
container if you learn the grasping
thing first and then then the container
thing then you'll be faster at learning
the the task of picking and placing if
you have a good learner whereas if you
reverse the order
you learn how to kind of pick in place
and then you learn how to grasp the time
it will take to learn how to grasp
should be trivial after learning how to
pick in place and so basically if you
flip the order of those two tasks for
one of them you get you get positive
forward transfer to some degree and the
other order you get positive torque
forward transfer to a much greater
degree if you have a good learner does
that answer your question okay and
that's something that's interesting and
worth keeping in mind as you think about
and it can be useful for thinking about
how do you actually order the tasks okay
so now that we've spent a long time on
the problem statement let's actually
talk about some of perches for solving
it and we can start with the very basic
approaches so and by basic I mean really
the most naive things you could imagine
doing so the first approach you could
imagine doing under settings where you
don't have a lot of constraints on what
you're allowed to do with the data is
just store all the data that you've seen
so far and train on it until you achieve
the optimal loss function for all the
day that you've seen and this is this
actually it has a name to it so it's
called the follow-the-leader algorithm
and it's actually if you have the
ability to do this then this is an
extremely strong approach basically
saying given all the data that you've
seen so far train on it and minimize the
loss and all that data and it will
achieve very strong performance because
you won't necessarily over fit to the
most recent data because you'll be
continuously training on everything yeah
downsides is that it's very
computationally intensive so if at every
single time you see a new data point
you're now trained on everything you've
seen then the your training time is
actually worse than oh of n because as
you see more data you presumably be have
to do more computation that said if you
kind of continuously fine-tune instead
of trying to train from scratch on at
every time step use instead kind of
fine-tune from what you learned before
then it may actually be more practical
to do this it could also be memory
intensive so if you're in applications
where you can't store all the data
you've seen then this is a problem if
you're in applications where you can
store all the data this is fine so this
depends on the application
okay I second that you've approached
that you could imagine doing is
particularly if you're in a setting
where you can't store data you just
imagine taking a gradient step on the
data point that you observe and this
corresponds to stochastic gradient
descent as many of us should all know
and what you've been using in your
homework this is very computationally
cheap it requires no memory and
downsides is that it's subject to
negative backward transfer if you if the
data points that it sees do not kind of
cover the things that it's all
previously and this is what is known as
forgetting sometimes also referred to as
catastrophic forgetting
how catastrophic it is depends on the
application that you're in so maybe it's
fine that you forgot how to do long
division for example it that's really
not a catastrophe but maybe in other
settings if you forget how to make
decisions based on the current season
then that is potentially more
catastrophic yeah yeah so the way that
the first setting of voice forgetting is
that it just stores all the data that
it's seen and continuously replays that
data and continuously trains on that
data right yeah so this the top top
version will in principle to follow the
leader' algorithm will actually trained
to convergence on all of the data that
you've seen so far where you store the
data and you sample it iid from your
buffer of data yeah it's yeah it's it's
with respect to something like regret
and in convex settings under certain I
think smoothness assumptions and and
convexity assumptions it may be X to be
strong convexity you can show that it
gets over again regret and login is
pretty good yeah
so for the first question if you are
continuously fine-tuning then like it
could certainly be the case that at the
beginning you get to a certain place in
your optimization landscape from
training on a very small amount of data
that is very hard to get out of and
there's actually some interesting work
by Stefano Solano that looks at these
sorts of critical periods and neural
network training and how that affects
training in later parts of later parts
of training and that's actually that
will hurt potentially both of these two
approaches because you could over fit to
small amounts of data or get to a bad
part of the optimization landscape and
so one way to do that is just to restart
like randomly initialize your network at
different points during training and in
principle like on paper the
follow-the-leader algorithm will do that
well at every single time step
well reinitialize your neural network if
you want to implement in practice you
would probably want to do some sort of
continuous fine-tuning or periodic
random initializations what was your
second question
yeah so in general I think yeah in
general in machine learning not just in
lifelong learning that like the
distribution of the data that you're
training on matters and so for example
if you have a highly unbalanced
classification task where you have maybe
you're actually like baking doing
medical diagnoses and like 99 percent of
your people of your patients don't have
the condition and 1 percent do then
rebalancing that a little bit and
actually help you get better performance
and then also in reinforcement learning
context for example if if the data that
you're seeing is is highly imbalanced
then it could be that you could do
better by rebalancing it in different
ways typically you don't rebalance by
using less data typically you rebalance
by just sampling the data in a different
manner in general I don't think there is
that much that is known about how best
to optimally balance your data and I
think that typically it depends on the
types of data that you're seeing at test
time I mean in practice you want the
balance to be the same as what you're
gonna be seeing at test time okay oh the
other thing the other note or other
downside of SGD is that it is a somewhat
slow learning process and so and that's
why we typically replay our data
multiple times I'd do multiple epochs of
training and that's because SGD it
doesn't update as quickly as possible if
you just give it one pass through the
data and so we may want algorithms that
can learn faster okay so the next
question is can we do better so these
are the two basics - I think - most
basic algorithms and in online learning
and continual learning and so I'll cover
a couple couple algorithms that allow us
to do better than these algorithms in
different problem settings so the first
case study that we'll look at is if SGD
is slow can we use meta learning to make
it faster in online learning problem
settings and so in particular what we're
gonna do is we'll revisit the example
that we saw in the last lecture where we
have
some agent that is learning to traverse
different terrains and I different
points the time it's these different
terrains and we remember that we talked
about how this form of like online
adaptation can be viewed as a form of
you shot learning where the tasks are
different temporal slices of your
experience but know what's gonna be
different this time is we're gonna
consider a setting where we see a new
terrain and we see data from that new
terrain and that setting might be
extrapolated from the kinds of things
that we learned before and so this is
gonna be an example of an online
learning problem where we continuously
see data from that terrain and we want
to be able to eventually learn how to
handle that terrain and so because it's
extrapolated from what we saw before if
you just take the last K time steps of
experience that isn't gonna be
sufficient to learn to adapt to an
entirely new terrain so how do we solve
this problem
one option it would be to continually
just continuously run SGD so basically
take the algorithm and take the SGD
algorithm that I talked about before and
just for each window of K time steps you
take another grade in stuff and this
will do better than taking one gradients
up on the last K and it will be pretty
fast with a mammal initialization the
downside is though that if you see ice
for a while you adapt to that by running
SGD and then you go back to one of your
other terrains
if you've adapted your parameter vector
and specialize it for ice then you may
not be able to do well on other trains
and you may also forget the the Metalurh
initialization that allowed you to adapt
very quickly in the first place okay so
how could we do better than SGG is
setting I guess the first thing worth
noting is that we can do better by
better training with it like a mammal
initialization that will allow us to
adapt more quickly but we can also do
better than that and try to solve the
second problem so we can view this as a
form of online inference so at each
point in time we want to be able to
identify the tasks that we're in and we
may not be able to observe that task so
for example when we round ice you may
not be able to observe that we're
nice and when we moved back to another
train you need to be able to infer from
the data that we're on a new train so
what we'll do
and in this case task is corresponding
to the train that we're on or the model
the dynamics model that we're under and
it may not correspond to it like a
semantic task that you're trying to
accomplish okay so we want to be able to
infer the terrain or the task at each
time step and once we do that what we're
gonna do is we're gonna have a mixture
of a mixture model of parameters one for
each of the tasks that we have and once
we infer the tasks that were in we can
then just run the parameters correspond
to that task for planning so in
particular we'll have a mixture of
neural network parameters over I your
task variable and for each of those
mixture components we'll take an SGD
step on that component when we think
that we're in that data regime so you
can actually formulate this as an
expectation maximization problem where
the e step is going to correspond to
estimating which terrain you're on or
which task you're in given your data so
let's say that the your your let's just
kind of simplify the notation and say
that the last K time steps of data s at
a is just going to correspond to XT and
YT for a given time step and the way
that we can estimate which tasks were in
will look like this so we want to be
able to estimate the probability that
we're in task I given the data at the
current time step and so what we'll do
is we'll multiply the likelihood of the
data under each of the tasks so say well
imagine that we're under task I look at
the likelihood of being under task i and
then we'll multiply that by the prior
that we're in task I so this can tell us
a so the probability that the current
terrain corresponds to a particular task
okay so once we have a set of parameter
but was he identified which task we're
in we can then update the parameters
correspond to that task by just taking
an SGD step
and we can do that actually in a soft
way so we can we can have these
probabilities be continuous
probabilities and then we'll take a
gradient step so we'll have a great
parameter vector for each task and then
we'll take a gradient descent step that
is on each mixture element weighted by
the probability of the task so this is
just the probability of the task right
here and we'll take a gradient step on
the data that we observed for that task
so if this probability is 0 if we're not
in that terrain we won't update the
parameters for that task or that terrain
and if we are in that terrain for
example of the probabilities one or very
high then we'll take a gradient step
using that data any questions on how
this works yeah yeah this is a good
question so what we did for that is you
can basically allow it to instantiate
new tasks and so and basically allow it
to incrementally grow the number of
tasks the disease and in particular what
you can use is you can use something
called a Chinese restaurant process
prior that corresponds the prior
probability that you're in a new
situation or in a new task or a new
terrain and then if you think that you
the probability so there'll be
probability of being under any of the
trends that you've seen previously and
there will also be a probability of
being in a new terrain and to evaluate
that probability we'll have the prior
term corresponding to the Chinese
restaurant process prior and then we'll
also have likelihood of the data if you
reinitialize to the medal earned
initialization to the to the prior take
one gradient step on that terrain and
see the likelihood of how well that
explains the data versus all the other
tasks one downside is that you may add a
lot of tasks and so at some point you
may need to refresh the tasks or kind of
remove the tasks that you haven't seen
recently yeah
so you're asking how do you evaluate so
it's definitely someone a topic modeling
and like you're surely processing the
you're asking how do you evaluate
whether or not you are in like whether
or not a task corresponds to a Turin
yeah so we are given both like each time
said we are given we're doing um like
model-based reinforcement learning so
we're learning a dynamics model and so
we have actually the labels which is
basically the next state and so that can
tell us at the that can allow us to
explain whether or not to identify
whether or not a given point in our data
stream corresponds to a certain model by
looking at the likelihood of that data
under our model in terms of identifying
whether or not you're in a kind of one
the task so you seen previously versus a
new task you can basically for a new
tasks you can just reset to your meddler
initialization and take one gradient
stop and see if that explains the data
better that gets a higher likelihood on
the data compared to the the other
parameter vectors that you have does
that answer your question yeah yeah so
in this setting so this is maintaining
multiple models it's maintained like a
mixture model of of models one of the
benefits that you get is that you can
with multiple models you can potentially
adopt in zero shot or in like one shot
like once you very quick once you
basically see that see a data point you
can use that to identify which model you
should use whereas some rough form of
kind of online system identification
needs actually adapt using that data
from a prior and it may be that you need
more than one data point to adapt so
this the recall is essentially can be
faster if you are maintaining multiple
models compared to having a single prior
the benefit of using a prior is that you
don't have to maintain multiple sets of
parameters and so that can also be be
nice does that answer your question
um so we do allow it to continuously
fine-tune on as it sees data and so if
it sees it as a train that was like that
is very different from anything that saw
before that will instantiate a new task
or a new model for that if it seems to
be like a mixture of two trains and that
and that explains and that those two
trains explain like a mixture of those
two trains basically a linear mixture
explains the data well then it will use
both of those it will use a linear
combination of those parameters and then
it will update both of them with a
gradient step that's weighted by one
half they'll update you tomorrow by one
half the strength yep
yeah that's a good question so in this
case we the initialization is is
pre-trained and then we invest on just
like ahead of time and then you run this
form of online learning from the
initialization one really important
thing to think about is can you then
take that data and use that to improve
your initialization for example if you
start seeing ice
you should then kind of incorporate that
into your prior such that you improve
your prior and maybe you can kind of
discard the ice model as was alluded to
before and just adapt to that from your
prior but you can't do that until you
actually start incorporating data into
it this work didn't study that setting
and it's important I guess one of the
challenges that's worth thinking about
is can you in fit like adaptation is
very fast because it's meted like I've
met a train for fast outpatient but if
you do an update to the metal or in
parameters that that update won't
necessarily be fast that will be like a
slow update and so it may not be able to
actually incorporate that data or a
small amount that data to change the med
alert the prior very quickly you could
imagine a form of like meta meta
learning such that you train it also
such that that ad updates the updates to
the meta learning model are also fast
but that would be tricky ok
and along those lines one thing's worth
noting is that if your neural network is
randomly initialized and you do this
procedure
it wouldn't work that well because the
adaptation steps won't be very fast and
you won't be able to adapt very far to
your to those new trains or those new
situations that you're in so having some
sort of medal earned initialization is
very important for successful online
learning ok so this is one approach for
using meta learning to make online
learning faster and also being able to
leave you at the forgetting problem I'll
quickly run through a couple of the
experiments that actually looked at how
this works in practice so in this case
the experiments looked at two different
settings at test time one setting where
the legs or the
the the creature I think it was like
called a crawler it was in a constant
crippled setting versus the second
setting was one where there was regions
of flipping between the lugs being
crippled or being disabled and the legs
being fixed and then the y-axis you to
show the reward that's normalized based
off of the performance of all the
methods in each of the two situations
and then there's different methods that
we can compare so the first thing that
we can do is online learning with the
mammal initialization as we described on
the previous slide you could also do a
mammal initialization but just run SGD
and this will do well at continuously
adapting but may forget and they kind of
specialize too much you could also do
the original approach of just always
resetting to your prior and taking one
gradient step every single time step
this will allow you to adapt quickly but
won't necessarily allow you to
accumulate data anyway if you're in a
setting that's extrapolated and then the
last two examples are non meta learning
approaches that either don't do
adaptation and just trailer in a single
model or learn a model and fine-tune
that model with grading to some steps
but those grading some steps may not be
very fast so a lot of different methods
in the constant crippled setting we
don't we don't really expect to see much
difference between these these kinds of
approaches because you can fit a single
model to to that setting and you don't
really need to you it's it's okay to
kind of continuously just keep on
running a few these steps and so we see
about the methods do somewhat similarly
whereas if we have these regions of the
legs being crippled versus like not
being crippled first meddling is very
important to actually be able to adapt
to these different settings so we see a
big difference between the first three
approaches in the second two and also we
see that using oh is resetting and
running SGD continuously I don't perform
well because they aren't able to
accumulate data and also very quickly
switch between these modes
that's why we see the green doing better
than the red and the blue and then the
only thing that you can look at is the
TAS distribution that's learned and it's
it's kind of identifying which which
mixture elements to use at which points
in time and so what you can see is that
in this case the the tops we're
switching every 500 steps and it learns
it learns that in these increments it
learns to use these tasks so from 500 to
1,000 and 1,500 to 2,000 it always
identifies it very clearly as task 1 or
or models number 1 and in the other
increments it seems to prefer using the
tasks with ID of 1 sorry if the first
case it was task ID 2 and then the
second one seems to prefer task ID 1 and
ends up specializing that model to the
train as it sees more data on that train
or in that situation ok any questions
yeah
um so in these I guess it's it's
choosing which like how many models it
wants to use there's a little bit of
greed yeah so it's it is choosing in
some degree to use three models I think
it's mostly dominated by one and three
though rather than two okay so now I'd
like to talk about a second case study
which is what if we're in the middle
we're not in the meta learning setting
we don't have a way to pre train for
initialization that's very fast can we
modify vanilla SGD to avoid negative
backward transfer when we're learning
from scratch and there's been actually a
fairly large amount of work in this area
and I'm gonna highlight what work that I
think considers a fairly principled
approach to this problem and that was
some work by David Lopez and Marc are
really Irwin's auto called gradient
episodic memory for continual learning
and the key idea behind this approach is
that you can first store some amount of
data per task in memory but only store a
small amount of data in contrast to
storing everything and you have actually
a fixed memory size and then when making
updates for new tasks ensure that the
updates that you make don't unlearn your
previous tasks and I guess the second
idea is or the second second concept is
what most methods are trying to doing
what most methods in continual learning
are trying to do it so the key lies in
how do you actually try to accomplish
- and what this approach is gonna do is
it's gonna try to leverage the small
amount of data that's stored in memory
to ensure that future updates don't
don't hurt the previous tasks that are
stored and by using the day that sort of
memory okay let's say that our predictor
is privatized by
or is f theta and it knows the input and
the task and the task corresponds to Z T
and then we'll help some memory
corresponding to M K for a task K or a
frittata k what this approach will do is
for every time step it's going to take
an update step on the data point X T YT
with respect to the predictor subject to
the constraint that the loss on the on
the stored data points in memory doesn't
get worse than it was for the previous
model and it's gonna do this for all of
the tasks stored all the tasks that were
previously seen this seems pretty
reasonable obviously just want to ensure
that the loss function doesn't go down
for for those tasks and we're gonna be
using the data points in a more in a
more weak way than if we're going to try
to directly train on them the challenge
with this is that it's it's hard to
think about how you would actually solve
this constrained optimization problem
and so one of the things that was neat
in this paper is they showed that they
came up with the idea that if you assume
local linearity of the optimization
landscape then you can basically use the
gradient of the task to rephrase this
constraint yeah right sorry I guess I
didn't put this in here but yeah you
also update the memory at each time step
and store a set of data points for each
task that you see and the the memory
storing mechanism that you use in this
paper was quite simple they just took
the total size of the memory divided by
the total number of tasks and then for
each task they saw they just added that
number of data points to the memory such
that it kind of filled the max capacity
but I think the more sophisticated
approaches would also probably do better
okay so if you assume linearity of or
local linearity of the optimization
landscape then you can actually rephrase
the second constraint as saying that you
want the the inner product between the
gradient of the gradient that you take
with respect to your current data point
and the gradient of the data points in
your memory to be non-negative this is
basically saying that when you apply the
gradient on your current time step or
basically apply GT you want GT to not go
in the opposite direction as the great
it's for all your other tasks and if it
points in the same direction as a test
then it will well it's if it's
orthogonal then and the space is locally
linear then it won't it will keep the
loss the same for all of those previous
tasks and if it actually points in the
same direction and has a positive inner
product then and this space is locally
linear then you will actually get
positive backward transfer it will
actually improved those previous tasks
the other assumption that this makes is
that the small enough amount of data
stored in your memory is representative
of those previous tasks okay and then
what you can do is you can replace this
the constraint there with the constraint
there and you can then formulate this as
a quadratic program and use QP solvers
to to figure out how to modify your
gradient such that the constraints are
satisfied great so in their experiments
they looked at a few different problems
they looked at permutations of m nest
where the pixels were permeated and you
saw a sequence of tasks corresponding to
different permutations of this pixels
they also looked at rotated amnestied
it's same thing but rotating the pixels
and also see for 100 where it introduces
five classes of c far for each task and
the evaluated backward transfer as well
as forward transfer as well as the
accuracy on each of the toss in sequence
and the total memory size that they used
was 5000 examples across all of the top
okay so here what the results look like
so you can see that the in general tso
gem is what this method is called it was
able to achieve higher accuracy than
training a single bottle on everything
and in comparative training independent
models on each of the tasks and if you
look at the what the right plot is
showing is showing the performance of
the models as you add more and more
tasks and it's showing I think the
performance of the first task after
seeing each sequence of tossin you can
see that it doesn't for many of the
methods it starts to decline due to
negative backward transfer whereas for
this approach is able to maintain a high
accuracy even as you see more data and
you can see fairly consistent trends for
the other approaches as well or the
other the other benchmarks one thing
that I'd like to note here if you take a
step back and think about this
experimental setup you might think well
do these experimental domains make sense
for studying problems in backward
transfer and and forgetting and if
you're in a setting where you have 20 M
this tasks or 20 C far 100 tasks those
are both settings where it's actually
very easy to store the entire data set
in your replay buffer or on your hard
drive and so they aren't necessarily
reflective of the kinds of problems that
we care about in lifelong learning where
we can't store data and so an approach
where you just store everything and
train on it would actually probably do
much better than all the approaches
pictured so something to keep in mind
when you're developing algorithms
there's also some algorithms that kind
of combine the ideas of these two two
approaches where we actually try to
medal learn how to avoid negative
backward transfer there's a paper at
nurbs that is covering that and because
we're out of time I'll jump ahead to the
last part was about online medal
learning which you don't have time to
cover the main takeaways that I want to
get across is that there are many
flavors of lifelong learning that are
all under the same name defining the
problem statement is
the hardest part it varies based off of
what you care about in your particular
application and also in many ways
meta-learning where you try to actually
optimize for fast learning I can be
viewed as a slice of the lifelong
learning problem where you want if you
really care about a positive forward
transfer and data efficiency and lastly
it's a very open and active area of
research okay a couple reminders again
project milestones are due on Wednesday
and to guest lectures next week Jeff
clean and sorry 11 I'll see you next
week around Wednesday